Le chat de Schrödinger, c’est ce chat hypothétique
imaginé par le physicien Erwin Schrödinger,
et qui à l’issue d’une expérience bizarre
se retrouverait enfermé dans une boite en
étant « à la fois » mort et vivant.
Evidemment ça parait impossible, et d’ailleurs
Schrödinger avait imaginé cette expérience
de pensée justement pour souligner le genre
de paradoxe auquel on s’expose si on admet
le principe de superposition quantique.
Et pourtant ce principe de superposition,
c’est vraiment LE concept fondateur de la
mécanique quantique, celui dont tout va découler.
D’après ce principe, un objet quantique,
disons une particule, pourrait par exemple
ne pas vraiment se trouver ici ou là, mais
dans une superposition des deux positions.
Et c’est vrai pas seulement pour la position,
un objet quantique peut se trouver dans un
état dans lequel une propriété donnée
n’a pas de valeur bien définie, et peut
se décrire comme une superposition de plusieurs
valeurs. C’est très bizarre et ce qui est
un peu agaçant, c’est qu’on ne peut jamais
observer directement ce genre de superposition.
La mécanique quantique nous dit «oui ouiune
particule peut se trouver dans un état qui
est une superposition de deux positionsmais
si vous cherchez à déterminer par une expérience
où se trouve la particule, alors elle va
se matérialiser soit ici, soit là» Donc
apparemment, on peut jamais directement constater
la superposition.
A cause de cela, le concept de superposition
quand même est assez difficile à admettre,
et le premier réflexe c’est d’expliquer
la «superposition» comme une simple
ignorance de l’état réel de la particule.
Ce serait plus crédible de dire que la particule
n’est pas vraiment dans un état superposé :
elle est soit ici, soit là, mais juste, nous
on ne sait pas où, et quand on cherche à
savoir où elle est, eh bien on découvre
sa position réelle, mais qu’elle avait
en fait depuis le début
Eh bien non, la mécanique quantique insiste,
et nous dit que ce n’est pas ça, que cette
vision n’est pas correcte, et que la superposition
est bien réelle. Pour souligner cette différence,
je fais très souvent la comparaison avec
ce qui se passe quand on joue à pile ou face.
[PIECE Si je prends une pièce de monnaie,
que je la mets dans le gobelet et que je secoue,
quand je soulève le gobelet j’aurai PILE
une fois sur deux, et FACE une fois sur deux.
Pour autant après avoir agité le gobelet
et avant de le soulever, on ne peut pas dire
que la pièce soit dans un état qui soit
une superposition de PILE et FACE. Elle est
soit dans l’un, soit dans l’autre. Mais
j’ignore lequel et je le découvre en soulevant
le gobelet.]
[MELANGE Après avoir agité le gobelet, on
peut si on veut décrire la pièce comme un
mélange de PILE et FACE, mais c’est une
description probabiliste, qui reflète notre
ignorance de la réalité. En vrai, la pièce
est déjà dans l’un des deux états, il
n’y a pas de véritable superposition. La
superposition est dans notre tête, parce
qu’on n’a pas toutes les informations.]
Mais ce que nous dit la mécanique quantique,
c’est que pour les objets quantiques c’est
différent de ça. Ils peuvent être dans
un état qui est vraiment une superposition.
[PIECE Par exemple si ceci était une pièce
quantique, on pourrait agiter le gobelet et
tant qu’on ne l’a pas soulevé, la pièce
n’est ni PILE ni FACE, mais une superposition
des deux. Et quand on soulève le gobelet,
elle se matérialiserait dans une des deux
configurations.]
Alors là je sais pas ce que vous en pensez,
mais à première vue ça semble difficile
à croire comme explication.D’un côté
une pièce normale, quand on secoue le gobelet
elle serait dans l’un ou l’autre des deux
états et on le découvre en regardant. Et
de l’autre côté la pièce quantique serait
dans une « vraie superposition ».
Sauf que de toute façon avec la pièce quantique
quand on regarde, l’état se matérialise
eton trouve soit PILE soit FACE avec une
chance sur deux, ben a priori je vois pas
bien la différence entre les deux situations
: pièce normale et pièce quantique. Comment
on fait pour avoir la certitude que les objets
quantiques sont bien des vraies superpositions,
si de toute façon on ne peut jamais observer
cette superposition.
Qu’est-ce qui me prouve que la notion de
superposition quantique est bien réelle.Ca
fait un peu arnaque en fait, la mécanique
quantique nous dit : «oui oui les superpositions
existent, mais en fait vous pourrez jamais
les voir. Mais croyez moi sur parole elles
existent quand même.»
Et c’est même pire que ça, non seulement
a priori on n’a aucune raison d’y croire.
Mais en plus on voit même pas très bien
quel genre d’expérience on pourrait faire
pour prouver que c’est vrai, pour se convaincre
que la superposition est réelle, puisqu’on
l’observe jamais directement.
Eh bien, aujourd’hui on va voir le genre
d’expérience qui permettent de démontrer
que les états de superposition existent vraiment
et ne sont pas juste comme une pièce à pile
ou face. Je vais vous décrire ces expériences
de façon stylisée, mais ça donne l’idée.
*** PIECE Imaginez qu’un jour je vienne
vous voir avec une pièce de monnaie et un
gobelet, et que je vous dise : cette pièce
est spéciale, je peux la mettre dans un état
superposé grâce à ce gobelet, et je vous
vous le montrer. Pour cela je suis venu avec
une machine.
[MACHINE : Cette machine ressemble à une
boite métallique, il y a un petit tapis roulant
qui rentre, et un autre qui en ressort. En
entrée vous pouvez placer une pièce recouverte
d’un gobelet, elle passe à travers la machine,
et vous pouvez soulever le gobelet en sortie
pour voir comment est la pièce.
Je ne vous dit pas comment marche cette machine,
mais je vous propose de faire des essais ensemble.
Et vous constatez la chose suivante : si vous
prenez la pièce, que vous la mettez sur PILE
avant de la recouvrir par le gobelet, et de
l’envoyer dans la machine, alors elle va
ressortir soit PILE, soit FACE, à une chance
sur deux.
C’est-à-dire que si vous faites cette expérience
un grand nombre de fois, vous aurez en moyenne
en sortie 50% de PILE, 50% de FACE.
Et de même si vous placez intentionnellement
la pièce sur FACE en entrée, eh bien…pareil.
Vous aurez en sortie 50% de PILE et 50% FACE.
Ok, tout va bien jusqu’ici ?]
*** PIECE Et maintenant je vous dit : on va
agiter la pièce dans le gobelet et mettre
le tout dans la machine sans regarder. A votre
avis qu’est-ce qu’il va se passer en sortie
? Je vous laisse réfléchir.
Bon là ça devrait pas être trop compliqué.
Que ce soit PILE ou FACE en entrée, on sait
que c’est 50/50 en sortie. Donc si je secoue
la pièce avant, à l’intérieur du gobelet,
elle est soit PILE soit FACE, et donc on aura
toujours 50/50 en sortie.
Peu importe le fonctionnement interne de la
machine, si on sait que ça donne 50/50 pour
PILE et pareil pour FACE, ben pour une pièce
secouée dans le gobelet il ne peut rien se
passer d’autre que 50/50, on est d’accord.
[MACHINE Eh bien là imaginez que quand je
secoue ma pièce dans le gobelet et que je
la mets sans la regarder, eh bien en sortie
j’ai toujours … 100% de PILE. Ca devrait
vous paraitre impossible, mais imaginez que
le résultat de l’expérience soit vraiment
ça.
Je répète : PILE, ça donne 50/50. FACE
ça donne 50/50, mais secouée dans le gobelet
sans la regarder ça donne 100% de PILE.
J’espère que vous voyez que ce genre de
résultat est impossible à expliquer si on
suppose que dans le gobelet, en entrée, la
pièce a toujours un état bien défini. Si
vraiment elle avait un état bien défini,
il n’y a pas le choix, ça devrait être
50/50 en sortie.Pas 100% de PILE.]
Et pire encore, imaginez que je vous montre
que la machine possède en fait un petit commutateur
avec marqué +/-, qui là était sur +. Quand
je le mets sur moins, la machine a exactement
le même comportement qu’avant, quand on
place la pièce intentionnellement sur PILE
ou FACE, mais cette fois on obtient 100% FACE
quand on met la pièce sans la regarder.
J’espère que vous êtes convaincus que
si j’étais capable de faire cette expérience
là sous vos yeux, ça vous prouverait que
le phénomène de superposition est bien réel.
Si vous n’êtes pas convaincus, franchement
revenez en arrière et mettez pause pour réfléchir
à comment expliquer ça autrement.
Les résultats que je vous ai présentés
seraient impossibles à justifier en disant
que la pièce a toujours un état bien défini
à l’intérieur du gobelet.On ne peut
donner sens à ce résultat qu’en admettant
qu’après avoir été secouée, la pièce
est dans un état particulier, qui n’est
ni PILE ni FACE, et que la machine a la capacité
d’agir différemment sur cet état superposé
par rapport aux états qui ne le sont pas.
Donc vous voyez que même si on est pas capable
d’observer directement la superposition,
chaque fois que je regarde ma pièce quantique
elle est dans un état bien défini. Pour
autant je suis capable de mettre en évidence
la superposition indirectement, par un résultat
d’expérience qui ne devrait pas être possible
si la pièce avait en permanence un état
bien défini.
Evidemment, ce genre de choses ne se fait
pas avec des pièces de monnaies quantiques,
mais on arrive à faire des expériences analogues
avec des objets quantiques comme des particules.
Et ce que je viens de vous décrire, c’est
en fait un cas assez épuré des expériences
qu’on appelle d’interférences quantiques.
Le principe des interférences, c’est d’appliquer
à un objet quantique une transformation qui
permet spécifiquement de mettre en évidence
les superpositions en obtenant des résultats
qu’on ne pourrait pas avoir en supposant
qu’on a que des état avec des propriétés
toujours bien définies.
Le terme d’interférences vous intrigue
peut-être pour désigner mon expérience
à pile ou face, généralement on l’associe
plutôt à une expérience comme celle des
fentes d’Young, mais c’est en fait exactement
le même principe.
Avec les fentes d’Young, j’avais fait
une vidéo dédiée sur le sujet, on a un
motif sur l’écran qui est sensible au fait
que l’électron «est passé» par les
deux fentes à la fois. Motif qui est différent
de ce qu’on a quand il passe soit par l’une,
soit par l’autre.
Dans mon expérience avec les pièces c’est
la même chose, on a dans la machine une opération
de transformation qui est sensible aux états
superposés, et qui permet d’avoir un résultat
qui s’éloigne de ce qu’on aurait sans
superposition. On attendrait 50/50, mais on
obtient 100% de PILE.
Vous vous souvenez d’ailleurs qu’on a
ce petit réglage sur ma machine qui permet
de passer de 100% de PILE à 100% de FACE,
ces deux situations sont en gros les analogues
des interférences constructives et destructives
qui expliquent les franges lumineuses et sombres
dans l’expériences des fentes d’Young.
Alors vous vous demandez peut-être ce qu’est
ma machine machine mystérieuse qui permet
d’obtenir ces résultats incroyables, et
ce qu’elle fait vraiment aux objets quantiques
pour expliquer les résultats bizarres qu’on
a.
La première chose qu’il faut réaliser,
c’est que peu importe ce qu’elle fait
vraiment et les détails de son fonctionnement.
Les résultats de l’expérience sont impossibles
à expliquer sans la possibilité de superposition,
donc même sans comprendre ce que fait la
machine, le résultat est là.
Ensuite, je vous ai décrit ici une expérience
assez abstraite, mais avec n’importe quel
système quantique dont il existe deux états
classiques, on peut, au moins en principe,
construire un dispositif qui va permettre
d’obtenir ce genre de résultats.Vous
pouvez le faire avec le spin des électrons
ou la polarisation des photons par exemple.
Pour ceux que ça intéresse et qui connaissent
la mécanique quantique, je donne des détails
mathématiques dans le billet de blog qui
accompagne la vidéo. En gros il « suffit »
d’avoir un hamiltonien dont l’opérateur
d’évolution réalise une certaine rotation
dans l’espace de Hilbert des états, et
on peut faire ce genre de choses avec n’importe
quel système à deux états.
Avec les réglages qui vont bien, on a une
transformation qui fait passer un état propre,
PILE ou FACE, dans un état superposé 50/50.
Donc on a l’impression que la machine secoue
le gobelet tout simplement.
Mais la même transformation fera passer l’état
superposé PILE+FACE dans l’état 100% PILE.
Ou 100% face avec mon petit commutateur qui
permet de faire la transformation inverse.
Et on pourrait même imaginer tous les intermédiaires.
Voilà c’est tout pour cette vidéo courte
mais importante pour la suite de cette série
consacrée aux Fondements de la mécanique
quantique. Car je voulais vraiment vous montrer
comment on se convainc que les superpositions
quantiques sont réelles, et je voulais le
faire en utilisant l’expérience minimale,
la plus simple et la plus pure possible.
On l’a dit, les fentes d’Young démontrent
déjà cela dans un cas particulier, mais
le phénomène d’interférences quantiques
est très général, et il peut en principe
être mis en évidence sur n’importe quel
type d’états superposés, et ça donne
le genre de résultats contre-intuitifs qu’on
a vu aujourd’hui.
D’ailleurs j’aurai l’occasion de réutiliser
mon expérience avec la machine et la pièce
quantique dans d’autres vidéos, donc j’espère
que les explications vous auront convaincu.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui, abonnez
vous si ça n’est pas le cas, mettez la
cloche pour ne rien rater des prochaines vidéos
de cette série sur les fondements de la mécanique
quantique, et je vous dit à très vite pour
une nouvelle vidéo, à bientôt. POSE MINIATURE